so you're in U.S wanting to help with
midterms because you're you think the
last hope for everybody around the world
is America and you said you fully
support Second Amendment yes you fully
support all that stuff how different is
freedom of speech in America second
amendment in America than it is in UK so
we kind of get you can get some Optics
yeah it's wild so I was in the back for
Uber yesterday and this lovely lady was
driving and I said something about
um difference in driving in the UK us to
say it's different because you guys
could have a weapon in your car and
people kind of have some respect for
that where I live we're not allowed
weapons we don't have a second amendment
we're not allowed to be armed our police
officers are not armed on the streets of
the UK they don't carry weapons we have
armed response units did you know that
police officers in UK are not armed yes
they have whistles and batons right they
have a whistle a whistle that stops all
crime they got a baton yeah yeah they'll
beat some ass with yeah they've got
literally that that is literally the
future what's the logic behind that
though
this weird and so I'm British but I'm
more American with the 2A thing right
this weird British idea that if you
don't have guns it makes you safer and
so when let's just say Jihadi comes up
and goes on a stabbing spree as they did
on Westminster Bridge he just stabbed
the police officer yeah and there's they
have just a whistle to blow
I've had a lot of whistles I've never
seen a whistle stop growing all this no
but they they only just don't have a
whistle they've got batons they've got
they've got other item they just don't
have guns what does that do with a knife
though or a car like I'm not here to
defend uh British police or their
mentality I'm letting you know they just
have more than a whistle well yeah but
if the car is coming at you at least a
cop would be able to shoot through the
windshield because I mean like she just
mentioned knives are are prevalent and a
car bro does a lot of them throw a baton
Through a Windshield unless your aim is
amazing and it loops around but no you
need a gun bro you need you need a gun
yeah so Brits do not understand exactly
remember they do not understand gums
Piers Morgan is totally anti-second
Amendment he sounds like a like he can
he he's he sounds like a smart guy how
is he anti-second Amendment not
believing him you know even cops or
people having guns it's the wildest
thing uh that's not the only thing Piers
Morgan has been disgusting about he was
disgusting about lockdown he was pushing
the vaccine passport he believed people
shouldn't even be allowed to go anywhere
near any form of travel if they didn't
have a vaccine passport he was The
Pusher of the whole lockdown stuff that
went on so don't even bring up Piers
Morgan so that was part one of your
question was about weapons part two of
something else yeah I'm like freedom of
speech so you're saying hey you guys
have you still have freedom of this some
people will see it's kind of gradually
gone away uh and you know some things
are being you know but still how
different is that in UK so for us we
have such a large web of
um hate speech laws so it effectively
truth becomes hate speech and therefore
if you speak the truth it's an
arrestable offense I've been arrested
for a column in a newspaper for example
we have people arrested for comments on
chat groups or if you make a comment on
a Facebook page that is not deemed as
appropriate that is hate speech police
officers turn up at your door and arrest
people and arguably you've got hints of
that here when you have the FBI turning
up at James O'Keefe's door for no
apparent reason other than he's on the
wrong team
um so certainly for us when I left the
UK a couple months ago the last thing I
did was a big stand-up night uh in a
theater with a guy that is just doing
similar to what I do that guy is now in
prison in the UK he was sentenced that
week when we got off stage he was
sentenced to five and a half years in
jail for speech for videos on YouTube
that were said to be stalking and
harassment of people basically doing
what we're just doing this he was just
bringing up different people Meghan
Markle or something it was a lot of the
BBC he was going for a lot of their
presenters but for doing this he was he
was uh it was the first case of its kind
and when you get new law you know you're
always in trouble new law that said that
that was stalking online store and he's
now inside five and a half years so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]